[Music]
far outside of town where the grass
never grows
and the wind smells slow and sour when
it blows
and no birds ever sing accepting old
crows
we're doing that that's the place where
the oncer lives it is not easy to break
into the major american animation scene
when it's already dominated by the likes
of pixar dreamworks leica and more but
illumination found a way founded in 2007
the studio stole hearts from the gekko
with despicable me which has spawned an
entertainment empire including two movie
sequels and a minion spin-off for its
ubiquitous endearing and maybe annoying
yellow boys
[Music]
idea
[Music]
meanwhile films like the grinch and sing
have solidified illumination's game plan
of making upper mid-budget films with
global appeal which means the studio has
yet to have a commercial done with more
movies to come we are celebrating this
studio and ranking all illumination
movies by tomato meter
[Music]
number 11 hop
beneath easter island in a giant factory
that manufactures the world's easter
candy the popular rabbit is preparing to
pass the mantle to his son eb but eb has
no interest in the job and would rather
be a drummer he runs away to la where an
unemployed slacker named fred o'hare
accidentally runs into him feigning
injury eb tricks fred into giving him
shelter but an oversized chick is
planning a coop back on easter island
starring james marsden russell brand
kaylee cuoco and directed by tim hill
critics say it's impressively animated
but hopscript is so uninspired that not
even james marsden's frantic mugging can
give it any bounce wow
why but i want to stay with you
fred please don't go i'm already late so
go away
oh come on man fred mate
i'll behave i'll clean up my mess i'll
do the dishes not your problem there's
no dishes in the wild no
fred but
i'm special well we're all special
ah you're not getting it i don't mean
specializing everybody's special like
with different i mean i'm really special
what are you doing
see
jelly beans
mm-hmm
so what
so you talk and you poop candy would you
do it in someone else's life no you're
right it's it's not your concern and in
two weeks maybe you can explain to the
children of the world why they didn't
get their easter baskets
easter
what easter
[Music]
no way
oh yes fred
i am the easter bunny
number 10 dr seuss's the lorax
twelve-year-old ted lives in a place
virtually devoid of nature no flowers or
trees grow in the town of the needville
ted would very much like to win the
heart of audrey the girl of his dreams
but to do this he must find that which
she most desires a truffula tree to get
it ted delves into the story of the
lorax once the gruff guardian of the
forest and the once-ler who let greed
overtake his respect for nature starring
danny devito ed helms taylor swift and
directed by chris renaud critics say dr
seuss's allorax is cute and funny enough
but the moral simplicity of the book
gets lost with the zany hollywood
production values
[Music]
now what
okay pipsqueak give me here come reach
out to the lorax
[Music]
where'd you go
babalutes
[Music]
oh that's bad
[Music]
hey people wake up
[Music]
uh what's happening where's where am i
hey we got trouble and it's coming up
fast
[Music]
we're in a river
number nine minions
evolving from single-celled yellow
organisms at the dawn of time minions
live to serve but they find themselves
working for a continual series of
unsuccessful masters from t-rex to
napoleon without a master to grovel for
the minions fall into a deep depression
but one minion kevin has a plan
accompanied by his pal stewart and bob
kevin sets forth to find a new evil boss
for his brethren to follow their search
leads him to scarlet overkill the
world's first ever super villainess
starring sandra bullock jon hamm michael
keaton and directed by pierre coffin and
kyle balda critics say the minions
brightly colored brand of gibberish
field insanity stretches to feature
length in their self-titled despicable
me spin-off with uneven but often
hilarious results
is no one good enough
[Music]
ah
didn't my speech inspire anyone to rise
up and prove themselves worthy
all these villains and yet i still have
the bear stuffed bear why am i holding a
bear
that was incredible
number eight despicable me 3.
the mischievous minions hope that gru
will return to a life of crime after the
new boss of the anti-villain league
fires him instead guru decides to remain
retired and travel to fredonia to meet
his long-lost twin brother for the first
time the reunited siblings soon find
themselves in an uneasy alliance to take
down the elusive balthazar brat a former
1980s child star who seeks revenge
against the world starring steve carell
kristen wiig trey parker and directed by
pierre coffin and kyle balda critics say
despicable me 3 should keep fans of the
franchise consistently entertained with
another round of colorful animation and
zany albeit somewhat scatter shot humor
look at that laser go i love it when a
plan comes together
[Applause]
get ready for that you're about to be
blasted back to the 80s
[Music]
oh
we got him
oh no don't worry there's more where
that came from it'll take more than that
to stop me
go get that barf back
bonus
did you see that clive all gone oh
buh-bye wonder twins
number seven dr seuss's the grinch
the grinch and his loyal dog max live a
solitary existence inside a cave on
mount crumpet his main source of
aggravation comes during christmas time
when his neighbors in whoville celebrate
the holidays with a bang when the who's
decide to make christmas bigger and
brighter the disgruntled grinch realizes
there is one way to gain peace and quiet
with help from max the green grump
hatches a scheme to pose as santa claus
steal christmas and silence to who's his
holiday cheer once and for all starring
benedict cumberbatch cameron seeley
rashida jones and directed by scott
mosier and yaro shaney critics say the
grinch gives the classic sioux source
material a brightly animated update
that's solidly suitable for younger
viewers without adding substantially to
the story's legacy
okay
now let's steal christmas
he swept up their presence with the
speed of a wiz
and he knew he'd cause sadness
only theirs now
not his
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all this excess and nonsense it was all
about greed
about meaningless stuff that they didn't
even need
[Music]
the grinch went to work
he scooped up the toys
he raced against time he raced against
joy
number six the secret life of pets too
explore the emotional lives of pets and
the deep bond between them and the
families that love them max gidget
snowball and the rest of the gang take
on new adventures and push themselves to
find the courage to become their own
heroes starring patton oswalt kevin hart
harrison ford and directed by chris
renaud critics say the secret life of
pets 2 doesn't teach its animated stars
any new narrative tricks but for fans of
the original this funny energetic sequel
should still satisfy i need captain
snowball for
top secret rescue
all right well i gotta go but nice
meeting you uh what was it yet okay you
don't listen it's daisy whatever okay i
got to get the dude to get the stuff to
do things
that was weird oh sister it's gonna get
way weirder
[Music]
it's snow time baby
[Music]
am i hungry
[Music]
[Music]
uh
is he okay not in any way no
hello citizens who is that
i'm captain snowball i hear one of you
needs my help
oh that's me ah very good
number five sing two
this holiday season the new chapter in
illumination smash animated franchise
arrives with big dreams and spectacular
hit songs as the ever optimistic koala
buster moon and his all-star cast of
performers prepare to launch their most
dazzling stage extravaganza yet all in
the glittering entertainment capital of
the world there's just one hitch they
first have to persuade the world's most
reclusive rock star played by global
icon bono in his animated film debut to
join them starring matthew mcconaughey
rhys witherspoon scarlett johansson bono
and directed by garth jennings critics
say second verse same as the first for
audiences that enjoy the first
installment sing two should prove
another endearing diversion
buster
ash
[Music]
you gotta be kidding me hold still what
are you doing in there
it goes off
crystal got mad and tried to kill me
what
i thought you were stuck come here to
finish me off
[Music]
i know
it's them
pretend we're not
first time i'll leave home in 15 years
and what do i find
the show's off and this guy's hiding in
a suitcase
number four sing
dapper koala buster moon presides over a
once grand theater that has fallen on
hard times an eternal optimus and a bit
of a scoundrel he loves a cedar above
all and will do anything to preserve it
facing the crumbling of his life's
ambition he takes one final chance to
restore his fading jewel to its former
glory by producing the world's greatest
singing competition five contestants
emerge a mouse a timid elephant a pig a
gorilla and a punk rock porcupine
starring taryn edgerton john c riley
seth mcfarlane and directed by garth
jennings critics say singh delivers
colorfully animated cheerfully
undemanding entertainment with a solid
voice cast and a warm-hearted albeit
familiar storyline that lives up to its
title which one of you is moon hey you
can't just barge in here you know this
guy
mike right mike here says you got his
money and it's in that box
no no no just hold on a moment here
that's prize money and it's not mike's
unless he wins it there and give him the
money okay okay hey hey hey take it the
whole chest it's yours okay all right
here open it
open it i i know
me open it okay no i i i just don't have
i don't have the keys so maybe you can
come back later
no no no no no no no way
hey there you go big guy with a bat who
needs keys right all right well let's
get this thing squared up now
what the
that's it
that's all there is
he lied
huh
moon lied to us all wait a second i can
explain he's your problem okay this is
just a problem so where's the hundred
thousand dollars
[Music]
monster look out
number three the secret life of pets
max is a spoiled terrier who enjoys a
comfortable life in a new york building
until his owner adopts duke a giant and
unruly canine during their walk outside
they encounter a group of ferocious
alley cats and wind up in a truck that's
bound for the pound luckily a rebellious
bunny named snowball swoops in to save
the doggy duo from captivity in exchange
snowball demands that max and duke join
his gang of abandoned pets on a mission
against the humans who have done them
wrong starring eric stonestreet kevin
hart jenny slate and directed by chris
renaud critics say fast paced funny and
blessed with a talented voice cast the
secret life of pets offers a beautifully
animated cheerfully undemanding
family-friendly diversion
see that's brooklyn that's when we gonna
get them dogs
[Laughter]
that ball of fluff's gotta screw loose
let's get down man but if you get it you
see what i'm saying bottom line is i'm
coming right to you tiny dog and that
big fat brown dog he gonna get it too
tiny dog there are lots of tiny dogs in
the city i mean you're a tiny dog okay
so let's just go he also said big fat
brown dog like max's new roommate not
necessarily whoo
max max max max max you are gonna get it
[Music]
that's kind of hard to disappear hey you
stay awake
wait what you know tiny dog
he's my friend and some might say my
boyfriend uh nobody says that i can't
believe you know tiny dog i mean that's
cool it's such a small world that's the
funny thing about it
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
number two despicable me 2.
now that crew has forsaken a life of
crime to raise margot agnes and edith
he's trying to figure out how to provide
for his new family as he struggles with
his responsibilities as a father the
anti-villain league an organization
dedicated to fighting evil comes calling
the avl sends gru on a mission to
capture the perpetrator of a spectacular
heist for who would be better than the
world's greatest ex-villain to capture
the individual who seeks to usurp his
power starring steve carell kristen wiig
russell bran and directed by chris
renaud and pierre coffin critics say
despicable me 2 offers plenty of
eye-popping visual inventiveness and a
number of big laughs
is it hot in here
[Music]
how's the food
wait a minute wait a minute are you
wearing a wig what
ah i don't think so i knew it you're a
phony i hate phony oh what not these
locks are all mine no they're not you
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna rip
that thing off your head and show
everyone what a bald-headed phony you
are i don't think so miss lady
[Music]
hello
hello hey gru hello lucy how you doing
wow looks like your date's up for the
count it's like she's been shot with a
mild moose tranquilizer
yeah i'm winking because that's what
actually happened excuse me what's
happening here she know like oh she's
just uh
oh oh
see and finally number one despicable me
super villain gru a man who delights in
all things wicked hatches a plan to
steal the moon surrounded by an army of
little yellow minions and his
impenetrable arsenal of weapons and war
machines group preparers vanquish all
who stand in his way however nothing in
his calculations and groundwork have
prepared him for his greatest challenge
three adorable orphan girls who want to
make him their dad starring steve corral
jason seagull julie andrews and directed
by chris renaud and pierre coffin
critics say borrowing heavily and
intelligently from pixar and looney
tunes despicable me is a surprisingly
thoughtful family-friendly treat with a
few surprises of its own i have been
working on something very big
something
that should wow this pyramid thing out
of the water
and thanks to the efforts of my good
friend dr nefario
thank you oh there he is he's styling
now we have located the shrink ray in a
secret lab and once we take this shrink
ray
we
will have the capability to pull off the
true line of the century
we
are going to steal
wait
i haven't told you what it is yet
hey
dave listen up please
[Music]
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you